>> ONE UPON A TIME, THERE WERE
WOMEN.
AND THEN THEY BECAME FED UP
AND THEN THEY BECAME CONGRESS
WOMEN.
THEY FIGHT CRIME, RIGHT WRONGS.
THEY WEAR WHITE, BUT THEY'RE NOT
ALL WHITE AND WE LOVE THEM.
THEY'RE THE WOMEN OF CONGRESS!
FEATURING NANCY "MADAM CLAPBACK"
PELOSI.
>> I'M SO WOKE, I CAN'T CLOSE MY
EYES.
>> ALEXANDRIA "I SAY WHAT I
MEAN" OCASIO-CORTEZ.
>> YOU'RE TRYING TO RIP APART MY
GREEN NEW DEAL.
LEAVE ME ALONE, I WILL DOG WALK
YOU.
>> MAXINE "DON'T GO CHASING"
WATERS.
>> THEY CALL ME AUNTIE MAXINE
BUT GONNA MAKE TRUMP SAY,
"UNCLE."
>> KYRSTEN "KOOKIE ARIZONA LADY"
SINEMA.
>> I USED TO BE IN THE HOUSE,
BUT NOW I'M IN THE SENATE.
I'M BICAMERAL, BIPARTISAN, AND
BI.
DEAL WITH IT.
>> ILHAN "GET THE JOB DONE"
OMAR.
>> I'M A PROUD MUSLIM WOMAN AND
PROUD AMERICAN.
WHEN TED CRUZ SEES ME, HE
CROSSES THE STREET.
>> ANNIE "RAISE THE ROOF"
KUSTER.
>> RAISE THE ROOF!
AND BREAK THAT GLASS CEILING.
>> ABIGAIL, "SAY MY NAME, SAY MY
NAME" SPANBERGER.
>> MY OPPONENTS THOUGHT HE COULD
HURT ME BY SAYING A VOTE FOR ME
WAS A VOTE FOR NANCY PELOSI.
UH-HUH.
HOW DID THAT WORK OUT?
GOOD?
>> AND RASHIDA "IMPEACH THE
MOTHER [ BLEEP ]" TLAIB.
>> IMPEACH THE MOTHER [ BLEEP ].
>> THEY ARE THE WOMEN OF
CONGRESS.
>> LADIES, THIS IS A MESSAGE
FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> CONGRATULATIONS, WOMEN OF
CONGRESS.
YOU KNOW, SINCE I'VE BEEN
PRESIDENT, WE HAVE MORE WOMEN
SERVING IN CONGRESS THAN EVER
BEFORE.
>> YOU DON'T GET TO TAKE CREDIT
FOR THAT.
>> THAT IS NOT BECAUSE OF YOU,
THAT'S IN SPITE OF YOU!
[ TALKING OVER EACH OTHER ]
>> OH, BOY.
>> AND YOU'RE NOT RICH!
>> THEY ARE THE WOMEN OF
CONGRESS!